>>Alec: With my peers, it's
really hard for me to apologize.
So I was wondering if
you guys have any tips.
>>Linda: A really important aspect
of learning is developing
agency and responsibility.
That also requires being resourceful.
It requires being metacognitive,
being able to reflect on where you are
and what you need to do to move forward.
And we see all of that in
the student-led conference.
>>Lynnel: So often in anything
that you do in education, in life,
students always feel like, oh, adults
are always saying their opinion,
I don't have a voice,
I never have any say.
So part of what we do
with the student-led
meetings is they get a chance
to say what their concerns
are, how they see things.
>>Alec: Welcome, everyone.
>>Dan: Alec led his own meeting today.
And we bring in all teachers, me,
parents, to say here are some strengths
of mine and here are some
challenges that I need help with.
>>Alec: With my schoolwork and
tests and stuff, it's pretty good,
but when it comes to
homework, it's really bad.
>>Alec: It allows all of us
to get all on the same page.
Homework really hurt
my grades this quarter,
so that's something I
really need to improve.
>>Linda: In student-led conferences,
we see students learning these skills
of how to articulate their needs, make
plans to improve, get help from others,
and own the goals that
they set for themselves.
>>Alec: The second I get home,
I don't feel like doing
anything else involving school.
So I was actually going to ask you
guys if you guys had any ideas.
>>Linda: Social-emotional
competencies have to do with the ways
that we recognize our
emotions and manage them,
the ways in which we interact
interpersonally with others,
the ways in which we organize
ourselves to get things done.
>>Alec: For me, it's actually being
able to sit down and get it done.
Because once I sit down to get
it done, it's going to get done.
Getting started is the
hardest part for me.
>>Student: Just staying
after and doing homework
with your friends before
you go home is a good idea.
>>Linda: Interestingly, the social and
emotional competencies are as important
as the intellectual skills
that we try to teach in school,
and they predict more of how
you do in school and in life
than particular lessons that
get taught academically.
>>Jennifer: I think it's about him
having to set goals for himself
and for us to give him the
best tools to work with so
that he can accomplish those goals.
>>Chad: And then, you be able
to see yourself in a new light,
which only gives you
more of that confidence.
>>Chad: The fact that he has eight or
nine, ten, adults for these meetings
to actually get on the
same page and say, look.
We recognize you're here.
We see where you've come from.
And we want you to tell
us where you want to go.
And just having that
collaboration is-- it's wonderful.
>>Linda: When schools and
parents are working in sync
around a shared understanding
of a child's development,
you get a much more robust
set of responses and supports.
>>Alec: Yeah.
I just wanted to thank Mr. St.
Louis real quick, and all of you,
for being such good teachers.
I think I improved more just
because I got a personal
relationship with all of you.